It's a loaded question with me actually
because,
um,
I'm,
I'm from Iran.
Originally.
I was born there,
um,
and the first several years of my life
we lived there and the plan was to stay
there.
Of course,
this omic revolution,
uh,
last up.
And so,
uh,
we moved to Los Angeles.
I was raised in Los Angeles,
but my formative years were actually
spent in New York from 18 onwards.
So I have a sort of ultra hyphenated
identity,
I guess is Iranian American and um,
Los Angeleno and New Yorker by coastal,
by cultural,
well,
at the time of the hostage crisis,
they were still in Iran.
Um,
and they,
because my,
my mother and my father were both
educated,
um,
abroad to a degree.
They,
you know,
when they got to the u s they spoke
English,
they were able to,
um,
work here.
Um,
it wasn't horrible.
but for them,
a lot of the fear came in just getting
out of Iran.
You know,
the airports were shut down when they
tried to,
to get out because of the Iran,
Iraq war.
And,
um,
you know,
they were basically sort of Gypsies
through much of Europe.
You know,
they were in Turkey than they were.
That's from there.
They went to France to Germany,
you know,
and then they've just finally went to
Los Angeles by default because that's
what all the Iranians were doing.
Um,
but it wasn't so bad for them.
And I imagine it wasn't so bad for a lot
of Iranians because they all thoughts
was temporary.
You know,
they didn't even,
they only had two suitcases with them.
Um,
so,
and,
and all their stuff is still and in
house they own any Iran to this day
that's left pretty much untouched.
Everything as it was when they fled.
Because when,
when they talk,
people talk about Iranians flaying maybe
they really did flee.
Um,
some of them made the decision quite
rapidly for some of,
for some people like my family,
it was an almost overnight a decision
because it really never seemed like it
would be permanent.
Um,
that's a very tricky question as well.
I,
as I get older,
I tend to become more Iranian.
Um,
but
I guess I've,
I've now,
since the novel came out,
been forced to consider myself as an
Iranian American more and more so my
family is fairly traditional Iranian
family.
Um,
but the novel really split me into,
um,
made me sort of consider being a
California and,
and a New Yorker.
So in some ways I emerged more confused.